en fait c'était tout simple
j'étais avec j'étais avec Catherine et
c'était une histoire toute bête en fait
elle a pris son son téléphone et elle
nous a elle nous a pris en vidéo elle
l'a envoyé à tous ces tous ces contacts
et il arrive il a arrêté en disant oui
c'est qui elle d'accord
et elle lui dit non c'est pas ma copine
elle a commencé pour être elle a mis sur
ses réseaux sociaux une photo d'elle 2
en fait ouais et voilà dans la story
j'ai vu qu'elle était avec une fille
donc Vanessa mon premier effet que ça a
été d'envoyer un message c'est qui il y
a les fraîche
et c'est pas de la crème
[Applaudissements]
j'avais déjà fait des bêtises avec deux
copines dans le passé
il va la pécho il va la baser le début
elle m'a dit c'est mort
j'ai demandé ouais donne-moi son snap en
rigolant je lâche rien d'accord et au
fur et à mesure qu'on a commencé à bien
parler avec Thomas je me suis dit bon
je lui dirai un peu plus tard et à
chaque fois je repoussais je repoussais
et puis je me suis et après avec Thomas
on en a parlé et on savait pas du tout
comment lui dire oui on se parle etc et
bah c'est vrai que les missions ça a été
vraiment une opportunité pour nous de
pouvoir lui dire mais
ta gueule
est-ce que ta gueule vraiment ta gueule
vous êtes toujours vous êtes toujours
ensemble ou pas ouais on est toujours
ensemble
donc là vous êtes ensemble
[Rires]
j'aimerais bien que ça s'arrange mais
elle veut pas
essayer d'arranger les choses en fait
c'est au début je pensais que c'était
parce que j'avais fait n'importe quoi
avec ses copines avant et qu'elle avait
peur que je fasse la même chose et que
elle perdent encore une amie bêtement
c'est là c'est d'avoir caché peut-être
là effectivement c'est le fait d'avoir
caché
je lui avais dit aussi que j'allais rien
faire j'allais plus toucher une copine à
elle au final
je vis avec elle au quotidien
et donc Vanessa peut pas venir à la
maison non c'est je pense qu'elle me
tu as perdu une amie toi c'est ta
meilleure amie bah c'était oui c'était
une amie très très proche avec qui je
sortais tous les soirs tous les samedis
soirs et tout voilà
après ça faisait pas super longtemps
mais il sortait très très souvent
ensemble et non elle est restée toujours
à la même bohème
un peu bohème
c'est la troisième fois que vous sortez
avec une copine de votre sœur est-ce que
tu serais pas un ignoble Charo
pas du tout ouais alors ça ça supporte
pas ça quoi ça je supporte pas pourquoi
non mais pas du tout c'est parce que
forcément il regarde s'il y a dans son
ah oui
4e c'est pas du tout
là
je vais te répondre
disons que depuis un an je faisais un
peu n'importe quoi avec n'importe qui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
des copines de ma sœur ah ouais 65 ans
mais bon voilà non non mais quoi oui et
là pour le coup bon au début je vais
parler je la trouvais juste jolie donc
effectivement peut-être pour le voilà
elle était intéressante très
intéressante physique tu vois tout de
suite quelqu'un d'intéressant
comme ça tout de suite je vois tout de
suite quelqu'un d'intéressant tu vois je
suis direct tu vois le tu vois c'est fou
quoi c'est vrai non mais clairement
tu aimes bien tu aimes bien la pop
qu'est-ce que tu as dit que j'étais une
[__]
normalement ne devrait pas avoir
vis-à-vis de moi je pense en tout cas
moi c'est pas le fait que ce soit une
connaissance en moi qui sort avec elle
c'est plutôt le fait que c'est ma petite
sœur et que la protéine et bien sûr avec
quelqu'un qu'elle connait pas alors que
ton pote tu le connais tu sais qu'il est
justement moi je sais qui c'est mon pote
technique il va pas être mon pote en
fait j'ai pas envie il y a des choses
que j'ai pas envie de savoir donc je
préfère que son amoureux son copain soit
quelqu'un que je ne connais pas c'est
leur solaire les regarde plutôt que ce
soit un ami à moi qui touche un massage
j'aurais du mal donc c'est pour ça que
je peux comprendre aussi un peu son côté
mais on n'a pas la même position son
grand frère de toute façon je pense que
tout ça ça va s'arranger les chéris
j'espère mais compliqué non t'inquiète
pas est-ce que je peux essayer de
l'appeler
mais tu pourras aller dans l'émission
demain ou après-demain
essaye mais je sais pas si tu sais parce
que je veux que cette histoire ça je
vous le dis et mamie s'il te plaît
va voir que c'est sérieux plus ça va
aller ça fait 6 mois et ça se passe très
bien pour l'instant vous allez voir ça
va s'arranger forcément ça va être ça va
faire ça va faire ce qu'on appelle la
boule de neige de l'amour
la version en tout cas d'être venu les
amours les deux franchement vous êtes
très frais et on vous kiffe et vous
revenez quand vous voulez